my good pal andy richter here as always
hey andy
hi conan how are you i'm good happy
holidays happy holidays how was your
thanksgiving
it was pretty good it was pretty good
and you
good yeah had a nice time small less
dishes
yeah no uh you know no going to see the
family
um just hunkered down at home
it's a tragedy
yes andy a tragedy that we didn't get to
go and see our
families this thanksgiving hey
i want to bring something up you
probably just saw it right now check out
all the cutouts that fans sent in to be
our audience
they're all now wearing christmas hats
and we didn't even do
that it's weird they come to life yep
and they went out and
uh all together decided to wear look at
them they look fantastic
for some the illusion's kind of good i
mean first of all this dog in the front
row
he looks fantastic ah right puppy
and look there's neil young neil young
uh sent
in a cutout the great neil young yep and
there he is he's in black and white but
he's wearing a
a hat in full color